CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi, everyone.
I'm Chris Broadfoot.
Welcome to another Google
Maps Developer Relations
screencast.
In this tutorial, I'll be
showing you how to get started
with the Google Maps API.
All you'll need is your favorite
text editor and the
web browser of your choice.
If you're feeling confident,
please follow along.
If not, just watch all the way
through to get an overview.
Let's start with Hello World,
or you could call it "Hello
Map." Fire up your text
editor and start with
a blank HTML page.
We first need somewhere
to put our map.
We'll use an HTML div element.
Next, we'll need to include
the Maps API bootstrap.
The web browser will download
the necessary code to display
maps on your page.
You'll notice the sensor
parameter.
You need to set this to True if
your map is doing something
with the GPS, like using
HTML5 geolocation.
If not, you can safely
set it to False.
We need some code to run when
the page has loaded.
The easiest way to do this is
to add an onLoad handler to
the body tag.
The code will run when the
page is fully loaded.
Inside the initialization
function, we create a new map.
Everything in the Google Maps
API is namespaced under
google.maps.
The map constructor takes
two parameters.
The first is the map container,
in our case an HTML
div element, and the second
is a set of map options.
Let's first ignore the map
options and just create a map.
Since the div is empty,
it has no height.
The map won't be visible.
We can use some CSS to
give it some height.
Let's refresh the page, and we
can see the div sits nicely on
the page, but there's no map.
It's just gray.
It turns out some options
aren't really optional.
There are three required options
to display a map--
Center, Zoom, and MapTypeId.
The center is a Lat-Long
object.
There are coordinates in the
world where you want your map
to be centered.
Zoom specifies how zoomed
in the map should be.
Zoom level 0 means the map is
zoomed all the way out, and
you can see the whole world.
Changing MapTypeId will
change the base map.
Here we're using Roadmap,
but you could use
Satellite, for instance.
If we refresh the page,
voila, we see our map.
What's next?
Head over to the Google
Developers web site.
Check out the tutorials
and documentation.
Before you make your map live,
be sure to get a Maps API key.
Thanks for listening.
Now get out there and
start building the
next awesome map app.